[Música]
para ellas no hay moda sin música música
sin moda hacen ruido en las redes
sociales las emisoras de radio y los
canales de televisión
son músicos y para ellas la ropa no es
solo ropa porque las palabras y la ropa
nunca son gratuitas ambas trabajan y
viven en brazzaville república del congo
mariuska la es la mús poetisa de slam y
spirit ananda se han unido en una
canción para denunciar los abusos a los
niños en las familias recompuestas
[Música]
fue una muy buena colaboración con
espírita trabajamos juntos en el titulo
maguana banda más buena banda que
significa el hijo de mi rival nos dimos
cuenta de que la mayoría de los niños
que viven en familias reconstituidas no
suelen ser queridos ni por su madrastra
ni por su padrastro por lo que era
realmente necesario que pudiéramos
hablar de esta realidad cuando me
planteó el proyecto vemos que
francamente alzador porque es algo que
he vivido y me dije que es importante
hablar de ello espero que el mensaje
llegue y tal vez si han estado en esta
situación o han visto a gente en esta
situación por favor siéntase libre de
informar si no podemos cambiar el mundo
pero podemos influir un poco eso sí para
mejorar ciertas cosas
[Música]
expedita en anda es músico pero también
es diseñadora de accesorios de moda como
estas gafas wax a los zapatos deportivos
así que la moda sí es una forma de es un
canal de comunicación porque a través de
la moda mostramos nuestro saber hacer
especialmente para nosotras las mujeres
y también nos permite ganar dinero ser
autónomas en alguna medida evitar
ciertas prácticas que no son muy cool en
el mundo del espectáculo y creo que se
explota menos la voz que excusa pues que
significa la moda para usted un montón
que van con goles pues bien como buena
congoleña la moda se lleva en la sangre
en nuestro país se llama más bien la
sape porque somos un pueblo que conoce
verdaderamente el valor de la vida
así que nos vestimos no por placer sino
para que los problemas no nos habiten es
una manera de devolverle el color a la
vida de devolverle la belleza a la vida
sentirse bien con uno mismo sentirse
bien vestido
7 por eso cada vez no dudó en colaborar
con los estilistas porque siempre es un
placer ver a una persona muy bien
vestida una persona simplemente limpia
de hecho que son promo
estoy vestida con ropa de él y cura su
haga es una diseñadora congoleña que
adoptó el estilo afro futurista y como
me gusta el lado estrafalario de esta
diseñadora me dije bueno para la ocasión
voy a destacar este conjunto
y pura swag a una línea de ropa creada
por otra estrella congoleña la
diseñadora y músico punta agua
pero mayúscula es la mús puede
prescindir fácilmente de la ropa de
marca para apoyar las causas que
defienden no duda en prescindir del
maquillaje y llevar una simple camiseta
en su canción es la mutua denuncia la
situación de los niños de la calle
durante los períodos de confinamiento
durante la pandemia los niños sufrieron
realmente los niños de la calle
sufrieron le piden a un niño que duerme
en la calle que se encierre pero donde
así que me metí en la piel de un niño de
la calle dormí en el suelo e incluso
cuando estábamos filmando hubo un hombre
que me persiguió con un palo porque
pensó que realmente era una niña de la
calle le pedía al equipo de producción
que lo mantuvieran en el clip así porque
me impactó mucho como la sociedad puede
ser tan insensible a la realidad de
estos niños ellos no pudieron hacer el
niño vive afuera el niño vive de la
caridad no queda nadie en la calle como
se las arreglan estos niños para vivir
porque realmente para mí si no cuidamos
a los jóvenes hoy es seguro que mañana
tendremos una mala sociedad porque está
claro que los jóvenes son el futuro de
una sociedad así que si no los cuidamos
hoy está garantizado que el día de
mañana será nefasto
para luchar contra todas las formas de
violencia mariuska la es la mús colaboró
con 18 artistas congoleños en el marco
de la campaña atos a la en colaboración
con el instituto francés del congo
también dirige talleres diarios de
poesía es la lección surge subo los
jóvenes son traumatizados muy a menudo
cuando son muy jóvenes por algunas
personas de mala fe y estos jóvenes
cuando no están acompañados terminan muy
a menudo como bandidos así que en el
proyecto es la united intentó aportar
una nueva forma de aprendizaje una nueva
forma de curar estas heridas con la
terapia que es el eslavo
porque para mí la poesía es la anp tiene
un aspecto terapéutico así que realmente
se trata de ayudar a estos jóvenes a
tener una forma no solo de curarse a sí
mismos sino también de rehacer su vida
pensé que mi arte debía servir para algo
no solo para darme las estrellas sino
que realmente mi arte debía servir para
algo para alguien eso es
para mariscales lemus la moda y la
música están íntimamente ligadas son
capaces de apaciguar en una sola
catarsis en poesía se podría decir de
mirada sin faganic delincuencial
insufrible por de pirámide póngase se ha
vivido una ciudad hágase pitágoras y las
tengo del círculo regional de paz
declaró un incendio en la ficción de los
tiburones uno dijo dijo lo mandó el
hombre fue la línea del mundo
[Risas]